ce n'est pas l'affluence des grands
jours le marché de mac ont subit lui
aussi les faits coronavirus même si la
plupart des gens affirment ne pas
vouloir céder à la panique il ya moins
de monde que d'habitude
ouais les gens ont peur c'est une
psychose causé ça devient vraiment est
bon on servait qu'est ce que voulait
faire
non non il ne refroidira pas n'ont pas
de problème je continuerai ville comme
d'habitude
pourtant les habitués les commerçants
sont unanimes les clients sont moins
nombreux une baisse d'environ 30% par
rapport à un samedi normal les gens
viennent moins ils ont peur j'ai des
clients qui restent london sont un peu
malade
ils veulent pas être dans les bons oui
du matin après y ait du matin parce que
les gens viennent vite il faut qu'on y'a
vraiment moins de monde que d'habitude
oui tout à fait malheureusement mais bon
fallait qui a pas le choix
pour l'instant il n'est pas question de
fermer les marchés celui de mâcon de
chalon ou encore de louhans sont
maintenues jusqu'à nouvel ordre